[Music]
okay so we've talked about the family
and that's one of the things people find
controversial about you i think really
though the one that you didn't mention
is the race and iq stuff this is
something you you
dive into a lot and i think people think
that there is somehow
a racist element to it so i don't want
to put any words in your mouth so do you
want to make your basic argument around
race and iq
can you can you sort of no no no listen
i'll be very clear about this because
yeah it's like saying do you want to
make
your argument that the sun is the center
of the solar system it's like well it's
not a personal thing like
this is not an idea i have come up okay
so it's not your idea it's not like
my formulation like i've got some
beautiful mind set of like
uh charts and lines in my basement it's
like it's all about the price of
magnesium man you know i mean
so i'm glad you countered with that
because in a way my question
accidentally was almost a setup so yeah
so i'll take that i'm going to give a
very very brief history of of
what it is and for those who don't know
where the science is and i'm not a
scientist so you know people verify
all of this i've got a whole list of
interviews with subject matter experts
on on the show about this topic so
listen to the experts this is my
amateur summation just for those who
want to know so
the the us army for over 100 years
has been giving more or less iq tests to
people to figure out whether they're
sort of officer material or
you know grunt material so to speak and
what they noticed was
between blacks and whites and this
becomes this bichromatic nonsense
because
the the question of ethnicity and iq is
a whole layer cake
you know just very briefly that the very
top the ashkenazi jews it is the jews
that are the uh the wandering jews so to
speak the ashkenazi jews you're sitting
across from an ashkenazi too can you
feel the iq just i actually am trying to
hoover up some
some language skills from you uh i'll do
it later with a straw but i i've been
dumbing it down for you so i know
and i appreciate that you know you know
as a caucasian i really need to go slow
yeah i love
lots of subtitles hand puppets and
health as well so yeah ashkenazi jews as
you know and
the science is like 115 iq on average
but lower on spatial reasoning and
higher like
even higher than 115 iq on verbal stuff
right i mean
verbal acuity among ashkenazi jews is
through the roof and the highest
recorded that there is
some of how this fits with our general
experience i mean what we're talking
about
everybody kind of knows deep down it's
just that we don't have the scientific
language or the mathematical language to
describe it
and that's what we're trying to do so
you know there's not a lot of famous
jewish architects or engineers because
jews test an average
around the hundreds in in spatial
reasoning
but crazy high on verbal acuity verbal
reasoning so of course you would expect
among novelists among playwrights among
lawyers
where high verbal iq is very important
you're going to find a lot of ashkenazi
jews
and lo and behold you do so what that
means is that let's say ashkenazi jews
said 120 125 verbal iq
and there's a certain proportion of them
in the language field but it's not
anything to do with
judaism it's to do with iq and so what
that means is that
if you look at any group of people
wherein they're in that iq
they're going to be equally represented
or proportioned
and then under that you have i don't
know the word oriental has kind of come
out of favor which is kind of
annoying in a way because how do you
differentiate people from india people
from
east asians whatever the chinese
japanese and so on uh
10300 405 iq in general
very high on uh spatial reasoning which
is why you know
software engineers uh other kinds of
engineers you see that you know like
google has this like it's like 40
or something like that of their
engineers or not much more because after
this diversity thing goes through
they're going to just have to pick
everybody by
color and all that but but this is the
thing right so if you're looking at
east asians with very high spatial iq
they're going to be quote
over-represented in those engineering
fields and so on but
not because everyone who's got that iq
is up there there just happened to be
more of those right
you've got uh your run-of-the-mill
vanilla caucasians coming in
at 100. then 100 is just i don't know
it's just that the baseline they
recalibrate it from time to time and so
on
and then uh below i i did some of this
what kind of mestizos or or uh hispanics
sometimes called oh that's very
loosey-goosey
term and uh that's sort of 85 90
and so on and then you've got uh blacks
uh in
in north america particularly uh african
americans coming in at
85 and there's been some upper drift a
little bit
and then uh below that you start to get
uh sub-saharan blacks
70 there are pygmies at uh in the high
50s low 60s there are
um the indigenous people of australia
i think in the low 60s and some of these
numbers again i don't have them all
tattooed on my you know wrists or
anything but so there is this
range it is unbelievably heartbreaking
i mean just just i'm straight up about
all of this like this is one of the
most difficult facts
i've ever had to absorb in my life i
mean i've gone through a bunch of
iterations
as a thinker you know i was a christian
and and a socialist and and all i mean
i've gone through i'm gonna go through a
whole journey
but i found almost nothing harder to
absorb
than this question of differences in iq
between
groups and this goes back many many
decades uh this was talked about by
hernstein uh in murray of course in the
bell curve
in 94 and nobody's been able to overturn
that and their basic argument
is to say look blacks
make less money than ashkenazi jews
but if you normalize by iq they don't
and this is
again it's heartbreaking stuff and it is
so difficult
to absorb this into your daily thinking
because i'm just going to
well i just want to pause you for a
second because it's interesting you're
describing it as heartbreaking and
struggle because that's what i was going
to ask you is that
because you do talk about this stuff um
i was going to ask you are you troubled
by it because i don't know that i've
gotten that exactly
through your videos but i obviously
haven't seen everything you've done on
this so hearing you frame it in that way
is actually different than the
a bit of the impression i had of you on
this oh
do you know how much i would give
dave to to know that it was just racism
because that's a solvable problem and
and people have been working on trying
to solve the problem of racism
for hundreds of years i mean it is
i mean i wouldn't say i give my left arm
because i'm left-handed but i would give
a lot
to i would give so much for it to just
be racism
so if you look at criminality
right i mean as you know uh black males
are
you know young black males three to four
percent of the american population
responsible for more than 50
of the homicides you look at what goes
on in the south side chicago
it's horrible and yet in general
it is not if you normalize by iq
everybody who has an iq of 85 has
similar levels of criminality
whites in america have a certain
particular
level of homicide that's pretty low and
whites around the whole world have the
same level of homicide
whites in england whites in belgium
whites in america all have the same
level
of homicide and
the question of course is environment
versus
genetics i would love to have a clear
answer to that
um science is making its way forward but
it's such a volatile topic that a lot of
scientists
you know like would rather do anything
than delve into this particular topic
but uh
it is oh it's extraordinarily
heartbreaking and
it means to me that no amount of
screams of racism can be guaranteed to
solve the problem and i think isn't that
what we've seen that the consciousness
about race
and racism has gone up so enormously and
and good you know like this there was
definite
racism in the world but without this
central
fact and it is a fact at the moment even
if we say it's 100 environmental it's
still a fact at the moment
you know even if we say well but is
there evidence that it's genetic
this is i'm not a geneticist genetic in
what regard i mean if we took
the brain of a 25 year old black man in
the brain of a 25 year old white man
what is it that they're doing that
different sizes
yeah yeah and again this is dependent on
every ethnicity the higher iq in general
there's lots of exceptions and so on
there are different sizes there as
evidence that um
if you take a um
a white kid from a middle-class
household for whatever reason ends up
being raised by a black family the white
kids can end up about 100 iq
if you take the average black kid have
them raised by an upper-class
middleweight family or jewish family and
so on they're going to end up
at about 85. so it does not appear to be
strongly environmental i don't believe
that there's no environmental causes you
know i've done
lots of videos where i strongly urge the
black community to
to breastfeed longer to to not hit their
children to do things that
will give their kids the best shot at
having higher iqs because that's going
to make a huge amount of difference in
american society and this is something
that
people need to talk about more is
equality and black parenting the quality
of black parenting
around the world but you know where in
america the most could possibly be done
is still quite
low they hit their kids the most and uh
if that can be improved i mean who knows
what could change how far do you go down
the rabbit hole of where all that starts
you know what i mean that they that the
most black people in america their
ancestors were brought here as slaves
that they didn't have equality for many
hundreds of years all of this
and then end up in poorer neighborhoods
then they get stuck on the welfare
system and
of course we're painting with sort of
broad brushes here of course but that is
the environmental factor right
yes and i you know there's nobody who
says no no sane person who says
any human characteristic is 100 genetic
um but again and i would love to i mean
i'm
very keen on improving um particularly
childhoods that's where i think the big
thing is
but you know a couple hundred years ago
in europe uh people were like a foot
shorter than they are now
and that was not genetics that was
environment you know not enough vitamin
d not enough nutrition as a whole and
back breaking labor and starting
in childhood and so on and so even if we
were to say
it's 100 environmental these are the
issues that we have right now
so let's say that that i could have been
seven feet tall but i didn't get enough
food as a kid
okay so that was environmental but i'm
still not seven feet tall at the moment
maybe my kids it could be different and
so on but uh nobody knows
how to improve it at the moment that's
the challenge you know you get this head
start program
what do they pour 100 billion dollars
into trying to close the black white
achievement gap
and with no effect a few little bits at
the beginning and then
it all generally tends to fade away so
it is something that
it it's a very difficult unpleasant
challenging phenomenon when we have
different iqs and we haven't even talked
about male female which again is a whole
other
challenge to to sort of absorb and
understand but
you know and it's funny because the left
is always complaining about i'm neither
left nor right but the left is always
saying
anti-science people are anti-science and
so on this is science iq
is a very very good measure it's one of
the few metrics in the social sciences
that
is you know measurable empirical it's
predictable right i mean if there was
some if people's iq was wildly different
from where they ended up in life
then it would be less valid but it's
very close it's a very close correlation
to where people end up and nobody knows
how to change disparate iqs yeah well
one of the things that you do in your
videos that i really like
is you often offer your audience a
chance to educate you and you say
send me links send me you know some
information that might change my opinion
on this so i think what we'll do for
this episode is we're going to find a
couple articles about this we'll find
something on the brain size we'll find
something on
ashkenazi jews and all of this stuff and
we'll put it down below and hopefully we
can get some of the conversation going
on this
uh because i think it's just one of
those things that
i it wades everyone into dangerous
territory and especially these days when
when everyone's accused of racism
endlessly
even if you're trying to find answers to
hard questions and i think we actually
i think both of us know we can actually
learn a little something from our
audience so
when i watch you do these videos and i
just watched your syria video that you
did the other day
and you said to people something to the
effect of don't just give me your crazy
theory
like it's not a theory i want a link i
want i want a paper
and some science so and i've i've had
you know i've had the subject matter
experts
on my show the geneticists and and the
social scientists i've had people
who believe that it's almost exclusively
environmental on to make the case i've
had people who believe that there's some
genetic
strong genetic elements and so on so i
am
gosh i mean it would be you know if i
could there were very few theories
that would be absolutely fantastic for
me to find disproven you know because
i've got a lot invested in my belief
system as everyone does but
boy if somebody could come along with a
way to say it it can be solved through
this or this is the cause or whatever it
is right i mean that would be fantastic
but right now
the problem of course is and people say
to me a lot and and this came up in a
conversation i think between
sam harris and charles murray charles
murray was on his show talking about
this
well why do you even want to bring this
up you know isn't this going to fuel
racists and isn't this it's like well
first of all
it's an important fact and and we are
tortured as a society by group
differences i mean i think i think
that's fairly
i mean don't worry we endlessly talk
about groups well they are real
and they're tragic you know when you
look at the the average net income of
ashkenazi jews and you compare it to to
blacks
it's worlds apart and and it's
horrible because if it is just attitude
if it is just
racism that's horrible and needs to be
resolved on the other hand
if it is to some degree genetic or for
whatever reason
it is what it is like let's say that
there's a group of irish people didn't
get enough to eat and they've ended up
being four and a half feet tall well
they're not going to make it in the nba
now we can say well maybe they're kids
and so on but saying the nba is
prejudiced against
these short irish people for no reason
whatsoever would be crazy
i always thought the nba was prejudiced
against ashkenazi jews but
here we go although you know the history
of jews and basketball right
i know you guys got it going right yeah
what are you going to do
i mean that's what i'd rather be doing
for after the show
yeah um but but the other concern as
well and maybe this comes out of being a
parent and so on
and i did weigh you know i read the
bell curve way back in the day and i did
way before i mean i don't just
get up and do shows like hey man
inspiration striking
you know i mean i did sort of weigh the
pros and cons
the issue is that um if the
if the iq differences are significantly
genetic
it's a tragedy but it's no one's fault
i actually think that if you think let's
say that you think that that um
blacks are the exactly the same as
ashkenazi jews and the question is why
the blacks failing
relative to jews you could say
racism you could say there's something
dysfunctional in the black culture you
could say whatever right
it's rap music but all of those involve
negative judgments about groups
right so either you know jews and and
whites and
and east asians and hispanics are just
horribly racist
well that's a terrible negative judgment
to make about entire groups of society
or you say well there's something wrong
with the black community because you
know you've got these guys from from
um what was it i think it's in nigeria
or something the blacks come over from
nigeria they have a higher per capita
income than whites
in america so if it's just racism i mean
physically they're indistinguishable
from american blacks a lot of them speak
fluent english so if it's just or you
know like
the great dr tom sowell who recently
retired you know wonderful guy and
i'm interviewing him in january i think
oh you're gone yeah we we're we're going
up to stanford and doing it wow
did you like hire doc the bounty hunter
to get this guy because he was it was
we did a lot of leg work for the last
like two three years hi you might
recognize me from the closet earlier
i really like the interview that's why i
pulled every driver my own banana good
no i'd like to see that yeah i'd like to
see that
so i mean he did well and nobody's
sitting there saying you know
so i just if there if there is a genetic
element involved or something which is
kind of hard and even through
environment that's
what we have to work with then saying
either somehow there's something wrong
with the black community or everyone
else is completely racist
involves dumping massively negative
judgments on entire communities
which if there are genetics involved or
other environmental factors that we
we don't as yet know or can control for
it's
incredibly bigoted either against the
black community or everyone else
for things that are beyond all of our
control and i
that to me is i don't want people
looking down at the black community i
don't want everyone saying
that we have this magic answer called
racism that explains everything because
it doesn't
it doesn't and you know it's it's
different in a way because
why do you think you're so passionate
about this topic particularly because i
was even thinking when i listened to
charles murray on sam's podcast and i
thought it was a great conversation and
obviously as they're doing it you can
feel they're wading into things that
it's uncomfortable to talk about as
we're doing right now
but i noticed that immediately after the
usuals cast of characters and salon i
think and
all the usual nonsense websites again
just pouring on the accusations of
racism and now sam's a
white extremist or whatever just the
nonsense is
so i think a lot of people just view
this as just the opportunity cost on
this is just too high
to even wade into it but you obviously
don't
i mean this is going to sound
self-serving i'm aware of this ahead of
time but
i'm going to be i'm going to be straight
straight up with you man
i want to solve problems in society i
want to fix things in society and i
don't
for the life of me i can't understand
how we fix things by ignoring facts
i i fundamentally i cannot understand
how we're going to ignore things how we
could solve anything
by ignoring facts maybe there is a fix
maybe there is something that can be
done i'm sure there is
something that can be done but if we
don't even acknowledge the problem
how are we going to solve anything and
i really really i find that the plight
of and it's not just a black community
but the f the plight of communities uh
around the world and
and in the western countries is dire and
we are currently tearing ourselves apart
as a society
looking for the scapegoats for these
group differences and
the science is very clear at the moment
about
what the s what the problem is we don't
know again all of the courses and so on
but i'm sure we could find it pretty
quickly
but if we we are gonna self-destruct
as a society if we continue to have this
incredible witch hunt
for racism and and sexism and all
like if we have we're just looking in
the wrong place and we're going to tear
ourselves apart
because this is not like the difference
between the world being flat and the
world being round it's not like the
difference is the sun or the earth the
center of the solar system
you can be a farmer either way you you
but but if this is like
our big thing and we are screaming and
turning over stones and screaming racism
and destroying people's lives and and
massive government programs designed to
to fix everything and
propagandizing children that their
entire history and tearing down statues
everyone's a racist
if if it's wrong we are destroying
ourselves
through ignorance and that for for the
society that we have and the information
technology that we have and the
communications ability we have
for us to to self-destruct
through ignorance of scientific facts is
unprecedented
in human history you know the roman
empire didn't collapse because they
thought the world was flat
you know but but if we look at what's
going on in europe and population
displacements and movement and so on
if we don't understand the basic science
behind what is going on
it matters it really matters about where
society is going to go
because if we ignore facts you know it's
like you've got some weird lump on your
body and i'm not going to see a doctor
i'm going to walk it off you know i'm
sure it's going to be fine you know
switch to decaf or everything i'll never
switch to tumeric i think is the answer
to everything yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's some some oil yeah but if you
ignore reality i mean reality just wipes
you out and so i am very passionate
about it because
you know i think too you know i mean i'm
a father i don't want my daughter
growing up with everyone screaming
racist at her
and they're going to unless we try and
figure out what the facts are yeah
it's just interesting i mean i can i can
feel the passion coming out of you when
you talk about it it's just interesting
because i see so many people try to wade
into this
and then eventually they just are like i
can't do it i don't want to deal with
the blowback
uh but you've you've put your position
out there and and i'm
happy to discuss this again you know in
a couple months well and
again people you know if you can prove
me wrong i am beyond thrilled i will
apologize to everyone although again
having had all the experts on our firm
ground again i'm no scientist but i've
had the scientists on
yeah well it's it's a good segue to your
book the art of the argument western
civilization's last stand
now i had douglas murray on are you
familiar with douglas oh yeah so i had
douglas on
about two months ago and his book is
called the strange death of europe
um you're so you're both sort of talking
about the same thing but at first what
you're talking about here
is that we don't even know how to argue
properly we don't even know how to have
conversations properly it's it's a good
jump off of exactly what you just ended
up very well negotiated very well
navigated with it
yeah how about that huh we almost know
what we're doing around here right
um what do we
what do we do to strengthen i mean the
basic premise of this what do we do to
strengthen
our argument we're always going to have
disagreements
and the question is how we're going to
resolve them and there's really only two
ways we reason or we use force
the only two ways that things get get
done things get dealt with we either
the two of us you know if we say we want
to go to a particular restaurant
you know i mean we have to submit to
where that restaurant is and go in that
direction you know i mean we have to
have some way that we subjugate our will
to power
and the traditional way in the west
post-socratic
with a few large breaks in between and
we may be in one of them right now i
think we are
has been okay if i make it better more
rational argument if my argument is
rational and sound and the premises and
blah blah and and the empirical evidence
supports me
you agree that we both submitting to
this third party
called reality truth reason evidence
right
and that way you and i can meet in
reality and we can both subjugate our
will to power according to an objective
standard scientists do it mathematicians
do it engineers do it all the time
there's a third standard called
a third party called reality objectivity
scientific method whatever right
and we have lost that
third standard the third standard or the
objective standard used to be
religious texts you know for a long time
under catholicism it was
what the priest said what the pope said
that was infallible you know
martin luther comes along with the
printing press and it all collapses and
into the reformation and religious war
and eventually you get a separation of
church and state
but if we don't have that third party to
adjudicate our disputes we end up with
you and i battling each other like two
pieces of paper being pushed together
you know we can't
one of us is going to have to buckle
under another one and that's where you
get all this bullying this escalation
this
pulling fire alarms you know throwing
fake blood at people and and
hitting people with with bike locks and
so on you get that when people
aren't able to find the subjective third
party to subjugate
their will to power their will to
dominance for and
if we lose that we lose everything yeah
so it seems to me that right now we've
you know everyone knows we've cordoned
ourselves off these days and because of
social media you only follow news
sources that catered away on
so but if we can't agree on basic facts
which really is what you're talking
about we can only do the dance of
logic and reason and really arguing your
point if we can agree on some basic
principles yeah we seem to be veering
into territory right now
where we can't agree on that how do you
think there's a way to correct that
before we get to you know it's the stuff
yeah or the argument
i mean you know i had a caller in to my
show recently is a a black guy called
into the show he had a great
conversation and he was saying that
there's lots of people in his community
who genuinely believe that mike brown
was shot execution style
in the back by a racist cop and
he wasn't right spoiler right he wasn't
yet it's very well
and so if there are groups who have
these beliefs
and there are other groups who have more
accurate or empirical beliefs
people have to submit their preferences
to objectivity that's
i mean i'm a universalist this is the
philosophy gig right you have to come up
with universals that people are willing
to submit
to because you know the old thing nature
to be controlled
must be obeyed you don't get if you just
make up your own standards of gravity
you're not going to get very far
but we do have to passionately commit
ourselves to
submission because right now i don't
know if you've ever had this in your
life i've had people in my life where
i don't i didn't want to submit to them
because it felt like a personal loss
you know like a personal oh we've all
got egos
we're going to win and i don't know when
i sort of relax and say okay well
i have these positions but they're based
on reason and evidence and i don't lose
if somebody
teaches me something better i win right
i mean if you go in the wrong way and
you stop someone and say oh you got to
go the other way you don't say you're
contradicting me you bastard
when you say well good now i get to go
where i want to go but we have to have
those objective standards and back to
the where we started
dave we have atheists who are not i
think focusing as hard as they could on
bringing forward these
objective standards atheist again should
be all over the race in iq stuff because
that's
science as far as we know it at the
moment but
they don't and i think social conflicts
escalate thereby yeah
so if we can't agree on the facts
but we can make what then isn't there
like this really crazy
that's it's almost as if society is
going to split in two in a weird way
two people or it'll split it'll split a
gajillion ways but i think that's like
sort of death star at the end of star
wars just had a change of direction you
know that's where we go right are you
are you a star wars guy
we could do star wars i bought the album
when i was a kid
the original the original do you have i
have it in the in the green room there i
found the original
lp man on the streets of new york city i
bought it for three bucks
like ten years ago wow the original 1977
was my one and then the poster that i
have in there next to the
makeup thing is the poster that came in
it which i didn't know i had until about
a year ago when i moved
out of the thing yeah i listened to that
and loved it because this is back before
vcrs and all this kind of stuff and that
was the only way you could enjoy it was
to close your eyes and
imagine yeah oh about what i would have
given for a lightsaber
i just like i just i've got a lightsaber
too no but it's not one that can take
down a telephone pole so
you know i'm working on that all right
wait wait we could do star wars
just going back the real rift here yes
there's gonna be a rift of like a
thousand different cracks and we're all
gonna
go in different directions but that the
rift will be
the people that want to have an argument
whether they agree or not so let's
you know we could probably sit here for
the rest of the day and find 10 things
we disagree on but we'd
do it civilly and we'd you know if you
made a point i'd concede it and i think
you'd do the same thing and all that so
we'll have that set of people
but then we're going to have the larger
set of people that just can't agree
that can't agree on the facts so it's
like we'll have this good faith group
that's going to be doing
it's going to be a small group but uh
but intellectually powerful
and rigorous but then everyone else that
unfortunately just can't even get out of
that world so it's it's sort of like we
have to give these people
a bit of a lifeboat or something i think
that's sort of why we both do well this
is you know like this book
i mean i'm hugely influenced of course
by socrates and what does socrates do
he didn't take a phd sitting in ivory
tower and talk about the ethics of the
babylonians right i mean socrates went
down
into the marketplace and talked to
people about what mattered to them as a
reason i do a call-in show for like
three or four hours
a week because i want to talk to people
and find out how philosophy can help
them and and what they're struggling
with and what
matters to them and right at the
beginning of the book by the way you
mentioned you know you're saying that
basically this isn't some academic paper
that's just like
some flimsy nonsense because we see this
now all the time yeah these academic
papers that get peer reviewed and
they're the most
what's it peterson you just had on john
peterson he was saying that 80
of papers in social sciences never gets
cited once
not once they just the library has to
buy them they stick them in a shelf
somewhere and it kind of makes me wish i
went into academia
no it doesn't i know i know it does but
no it doesn't do
that i know utility right that uh shadow
lands thing you ever see the movie
shadowlands
well it's a great bit it's a fantastic
movie but anthony hopkins
playing an academic is talking to some
other one and he says don't you ever get
this feeling of ultimate futility
almost like well of course
yeah but no i i wanted to write a
colloquial
book on on well first of all you have to
tell people why it's important
because everyone has this negative view
of arguments like what do you think if
you think of some bickering couple
um like oh man i remember this popped
into my head
just now many years ago i worked after
high school i wanted to save money to go
to college
and um i worked gold panning prospecting
like all this
really rough stuff up north stuff and i
remember staying in a uh
it's a bit of a rude story but i
remember staying in a lodge and
and hearing this horrible old married
bickerton couple screaming at each other
and um it got to the point where like
the man was like
yeah well your sister gives better
[ __ ] than you and i was like
oh i'd rather be in the woods like i'll
take a bear
over this kind of humanity and we think
of this like you know
there's bickerton stuff this maneuvering
you see this online all the time people
won't give up their positions they
they inflame they add homonym that all
this kind of stuff and so i wanted to
give people a more positive flavor of
arguments a more positive flavor of
of debate that it's a chance to be
informed it's a chance to learn it's a
chance to sharpen your skills
in verbal debate and that is
civilization civilization starts we put
down the club and we use our words
it's all we've got yeah i mean there's
no there's no plan c there's a club
there's your words and that's it there's
nothing else we've got no backup plan
there's no plan c
that's it that's all we have and when
you see aggression
and coercion escalating in society which
we see online bullying
and aggression and all that we see with
the expanding
state trying to solve every conceivable
problem we have in the known universe
because the state is coercion it's an
agency of force and that's because
force rushes in where words fail to
tread and this is why okay i'll talk
about controversial issues because i
know that the alternative is
if i back off and you back off and other
people back off from controversial
issues
it's not like well everyone just said
okay well we're not going to deal with
them at all
what happens is then people who are
sophists and and the violence mongers
they come in instead and they start
telling
everyone what to do at the point of a
gun and that's not good yeah and that's
really exactly why
i wanted to return the favor and have
you on my show and not just do your show
because
whether every argument you made here was
perfect and as you said you're not a
scientist and
and you're open to those challenges that
this is the only thing that's going to
get us out of this craziness so if
i'm afraid of taking some heat for
having you on or if you're afraid of
having some heat for having peterson on
or
whatever it is and it i don't even mean
you in this case so specifically
but any of these people if we all get
afraid of talking to each other
then it's really the jig is up the only
thing i'm afraid of
about having jordan peterson on my show
is that i'm gonna look like an idiot
because the man is so supernaturally
intelligent i'm basically just holding
his train
daintily and i believe that the uh the
top comment on my interview with him
from last week was dave you're an idiot
so you have to have you know some
humility
around that you know listen it was a
pleasure talking to you i hope we'll do
this again because there's obviously so
much more that we can
that we can get into all right for more
on stefan you can find him right here on
youtube it's youtube.com
free domain radio
[Music]
you